now notice in the jeans did you have
these ones my grandmother did oh no
actually no so this pair of jeans I went
and got him they did a great job but it
was every pair after that they could
messed up so I've told myself I'm gonna
go to Walmart by sewing machine and do
it myself that's awesome that's
impressive
thank you we're welcome to boots and
hearts good to be here used to the
festival life now we are used to the
festival life is everyday thing for us
so but I had to say man this one here is
a little different because it's not
humid it's not super hot like it's
beautiful so we love this do you find
the crowd is different at a festival
crowd yeah absolutely yeah you know and
and the festival crowds could be
different within themselves as well you
know some are like totally into it some
are like oh it's early in the day I'm
just getting sick already
so they're all different but they are
different than say like a club or an
arena right or something like that I
feel even almost changes by the day do
like this is day two of the festival in
there Wow
yeah my day for it's a little bit their
wild on day to day one they're getting
started by day for two they're just kind
of like now one of the cool things about
this festival is to have the Chevy music
presents boots and hearts emerging
artists showcase so it's all like these
up-and-coming artists that are really
trying to get their big break what
advice would you have for kind of those
artists that are trying to get married
there's so many paths you can go to epic
break you know there's so many ways you
can do it but I mean just me myself you
know my deal was I moved to Nashville
and I met the right people I started
writing
music and learning my artistry and I
started playing shows there's no busting
on the road playing the 50 people that
100 people then just growing it slowly
and surely and so here we are you know
10 years since I moved to Nashville and
then we're finally getting somewhere so
that was my path you know that's just
the way that's got one yeah well that's
the thing that everyone seems to be
saying it's just like it's just a grind
like you just got to get out there and
just keep playing and playing and I
don't get in your head about it like
it's just it is what it is you never
know it could happen next week it might
take six seven years right just got it
out right now this is the family travel
with you at all and Jesus shows every
now and then yeah every now and then
we'll bring the family out brought him
out quite a bit this summer we've been
fortunate enough to have enough success
where I can have two buses me and the
fam got our own bus and we're hanging
out with my wife we're having a little
girl yeah in about three weeks
that's what it must be soon she can't
travel anymore so she's at home this
weekend yeah I was Beckett feel about
having a previous sister coming he
doesn't know what's up here oh he
doesn't quite understand it you know
he'll walk up to employers so they can
go baby you know know like yo you're
about to have a baby right I've have a
sister and you know it's about to get
real busy is he - yeah he's not - not to
move under - he's 19 months are you
ready for that I was laying in bed the
other night when I was home and I didn't
go to bed till 2:00 or 3:00 o'clock that
morning cuz I was literally lay there
going am I ready for this right but you
know what I am ready for it and I better
be ready for it cuz it's right around
the corner yeah I am dude I love being a
dad is the thought of man I had I had
two little kids that I have to make sure
everything's great yeah you're
responsible for I'm responsible bad and
I saw the one video that you posted like
playing your guitar in front of back at
like singing a song to him does he have
any like musical inclinations that are
seeing anything
absolutely that kid like I didn't know
what to expect my wife doesn't sing at
all like so you don't expect but I'll
start singing made and you'll start
singing with me he's not saying words
yes he's singing you know he loves me
love the guitar he loves the drums and
he loves singing so I got a feeling I
have another musician that's awesome
yeah now we have the nothing to do town
EP that's been out for a little bit you
must know like what's it been like to
like play these songs - fans like you
surprised it like a certain song that's
really the grab people yeah you know the
hold thanks across with it yeah I mean
there was a time when I released music
and nobody cared nothing they care they
just didn't know but yeah who I was
anything but now I can release the song
rocket Leeson EP and they learned the
songs and they came up to the show and
they scream the song back to the other
side best man that's cool and that's
like that's the reason I write music and
go out there perform music
so it's been a Miss think oh that's the
first EP or any music that I've actually
released where it's like immediately
right through there singing right that's
crazy yeah like artists often talk about
that like that first moment of being in
a show and they're seeing the lyrics yet
like what was that like for you that
first time it was my girl
it was it yeah very first that one yeah
I was probably in the it was probably
low 30s high twenties went off on the
chart when all of a sudden they were
like showing up and singing it back to
it you know it was kind of like the
first time we ever put 500 people in a
club like holy cow man there's as many
people here who think well you know the
same deal with the songs like I'm
looking around my guy was going and
what's the yeah with my girl like seeing
that success like yeah we were just been
talking about the idea of like getting
out there and putting in the work and
then you see you actually start to have
success you see it going up on the
charts like we're just like to see that
song kind of rise and I get away surreal
yeah happy that what you doing about
your whole life me Chris and something
like
time I was a little kid I know I wanted
to play music and perform music and
write music and so when it was finally
working like oh we have a 25 20 15 10 5
I do retire but be no more like you
kidding me like huh that's what we
that's what we do it for you know so it
was it was surreal
yeah that's right and you have the new
EP coming out is that this Friday comes
soon I think so August 16 that this
product yeah that's his front yeah yeah
I've got it's a Keith Whitley tribute
yeah called an old memory of me I grew
up with huge Keith Whitley fan like
everybody but he's the reason I moved to
Nashville and the reason I pursued music
and so basically man it was it's just uh
for two things I want to keep his legacy
going this is just a thank you
Thank You Keith Whitley for letting me
do what I did why did you decide to do
like a whole EP of it cuz usually some
people just you know cover our show or
something I could have done a whole but
we did six songs which was tough it was
really hard to sit down a go like which
six songs it would take
you know that's just the thing right now
these are the things yeah who knows we
may release another five or six next
year yeah no I know you're not going to
be spending much time here before you
take off but I mean you should get some
time to work on your golf game I've seen
some of you pretty good I watched your
video you tired a big game of golf
hopefully tomorrow we go to West Virgina
tomorrow but hopefully we'll golf
tomorrow but I love it yeah I'm just not
very good a big game for sure the best
really congratulations man no thanks I
feel like that